two months from today thousands of
nevadans lose
federal unemployment benefits local
officials say it is important to try and
stay ahead of that cut off
so that you can find work now and a lot
of places need
employers employees hector mejia live
this morning with a look at some events
this week
to try and help get nevada back to work
hector
taylor john and a lot of people are
hiring this friday for example the las
vegas convention center here will host a
large
job fair and today there is a push by
the county also here at the las vegas
convention center
to convince anyone who is still getting
unemployment benefits to get back to
work soon
clark county commissioners jim gibson
along with tick segger bloom will host
today's event
they're urging people to not wait until
federal
unemployment benefits expire in
september
those benefits are part of the american
rescue plan
all of the enhanced benefits of that
plan are set to end
september 6th and that could mean a
major loss of monthly income for the
thousands of people here in nevada still
holding on to unemployment
so the commissioners want everyone to
start planning now and here's one
opportunity
the county is hosting a large job fair
here at the convention
center happening this friday from 9 00
a.m to 2 p.m
there will be over a hundred employers
from the local hotels
manufacturing government and customer
service industries
walk-ins are welcome but
pre-registration through the envy career
center website is suggested in clark
county estimates
this will be one of the largest job
fairs in southern nevada
also more than 12 thousand positions are
open and ready to be filled and we're
told some
employers will actually hire on the spot
so they recommend
for you to bring your resume and bring
plenty of copies
reporting live hector mejia 8 news now